okie dokie here we go yen the man that i
played this guy before and I don't have
a score here it's just exactly the the
same opening that I had before maybe try
the same thing could be funny let's try
do I get in night before this time yes I
do okay it's not it's not the end of the
world but it's interesting so let's go
see if I that is the idea of this whole
setup always amazed that people play
this in like 10 seconds yeah like it's
total crap what I'm doing maybe it is
but still I think you can think for
maybe like a little bit but no
everything is played immediately okay so
f 6 I guess on rupee 8 first hmm okay
yeah probably have six e6 rupee eight
yeah that's this is a kind of similar to
some some some other lines in the
sameish but yeah there are some some
little differences there let's see what
happens checking be too and not quite
sure if you can ignore this another idea
is to play look before at some lines
very very sharp position obviously so
look before is this move possible or not
you have six
well I'm not quite sure about it but
let's try not totally sure this is
possible it threatens 94 a question is
Bishop f6 is this really possible or not
cooling takes 95 this is not this
shouldn't work actually thing about 94
is the normal argument against this move
but ok well let's let's move it first
let's move first and think later
according to Willie Hendrix um 94 would
be two with the total mass and some
really funky complications there are
they said these ideas are known from
from the panel variation with 96 and a
six is just a little bit a little bit
different this this kind of thing but
the motifs are quite similar yeah okay
so i have to take now and at the end
this is hanging but i can take be too
hmm so
yeah yes i have to take and now
interesting i can take be tool yes
Bishop f8 i can take c5 as well leads to
a really rocky position now and then p 2
I can take be tuned knight on d5 is
really strong or Bishop b2 and Bishop e2
as a very strange more okay I'm taking
this one so just check really don't I
really don't know what happens here if
it feels like there might be some kind
of some kind of problem with what I'm
doing but it's it's still interesting
okay I can take the channel the beef all
night is hanging of course okay so what
now I have rupee for it's just better
maybe checking him first maybe him or
something not something but i know that
this doesn't look bad ok so now take
before him the ship t4 is no good I
guess
I probably not so I can take before how
do i take it down with the bishop over
the night and with the bishop or with
the rook sorry yeah I'm not sure really
a lot so let's put this out check the
apron I've got two minor pieces for the
rook after this valid complications but
as usual I've lost time okay okay yeah
this is hanging with a check
unfortunately so probably have to have
to push this that wasn't wasn't great
from a technical point of view time
morning Roxy 554 but it's just a piece
yep let's go back and try to coordinate
and okay it's nice for me but not easy
not easy to win
very likely that it will end in some
with some draw 50 seconds mm-hmm have to
coordinate my pieces okay if it takes on
the 7-eleven ich chances increase but he
probably just wants to pin me a little
bit unfortunately I cannot play 95 I'm
pinned check HERE kinky five chat only
not helping me much but can still do
this first maybe here 495 I have to
unpin
hm not easy to to make any any kind of
progress him can i maybe somehow trap
his rocker this is an idea check
difficult down he's six yeah cause white
has no idea whatsoever but it's just
impossible for him to do much but I
cannot really make any progress myself
okay so let's let's see if I can get I
can get one piece traded didn't like to
don't like to trade the bishop much but
ok I give I've given up this pawn down
ok i know my winning chances are
basically zero
yeah it's it's just a draw but I have 16
seconds check check
96 is coming check bra offered check
game wrong okay it's nice that she
conceded the draw them not winning on
time yeah okay thats it's better i
really should have won this probably but
i have to really keep the a pond that's
it's important i guess without the a
pond it gets it gets tricky it's really
tricky to win oh no i forgot about 97
that's bad i was earlier you know what I
overlooked this I saw that there's there
are those ideas but I already forgot
that 97 look a 7 is no check anymore so
yeah yeah okay so this was the this was
a crucial point I think after 97 black
wins fairly easily actually I have a
great spot now here for them for the
bishop won't be six is anchored and then
I can probably win the apron and with it
the game okay well okay this was a very
wild game anyway very difficult to to to
assess maybe there was some some
windfall for both of us it's really
possible yeah look before computer gives
000 funny yeah those ideas are known
from the sameish so i really knew that
this kind of thing might work but of
course i didn't didn't work out the
details but it's quite funny that the
counter really gives 000 but King f2 is
a blunder yes to go to d1 this is just
essentially can't blundering blundering
this route be one is better though with
better chances to defend yeah after that
should win but I didn't see that 97 is
brew is covering the same of the rank so
that he's not able to take this check
yeah in this situation here of course
Black is still quite clear
you better but how do you win this am
that's um that's an entirely different
matter maybe I mean clearly betters it's
the wrong way to phrase it i mean if
anybody can do something it's black but
how do you really win this hmm i don't
know i don't know if this is possible
probably not yeah there are probably too
many ways for y to give up his rook form
um yeah in the process to give black
young just one single piece at the end
that cannot win probably okay it was an
interesting game though thanks for
watching